but will they come looking for you over
there how many hidden references did you
catch in disney's flick luca
disney notoriously includes smart and
sneaky references throughout their films
today we're taking a look at some of our
favorite hidden details from disney
movies
how does luca connect to a future disney
film which memorable bird appears in
raya and the last dragon
really as we venture with joe gardner
and 22
through the streets of new york in seoul
a travel agency is seen with a poster
advertising flights to porto rosso
this was a clever nod to the film luca
which was one of the next disney films
to come out at the time
there is even more to the name portorosa
though
it's actually a sneaky reference to the
old italian movie called
porco rosso
is about to begin this cool scooter in
lucca
is way cooler when we take a look at the
license plate
it may seem like some random numbers but
if we reverse them
we get 0 2 2 5. what's so special about
these numbers
well they make up the date of the day
that the very first teaser trailer for
luca was released online
february 25th ah yes
in the middle of the town we see a
newspaper stand and if we look closely
we see the names of the newspapers one
of which is la gazetta
if you ever wanted to get your hands on
a real copy you're actually in luck
la gazzetta is a real italian sports
newspaper
bravo we did it luca had quite a few
references and one very special
connection to disney's the little
mermaid
in this scene luca's mother warns him
not to get too close to the surface of
the water
because he could be harmed by the humans
sound like a familiar warning
it's extremely similar to the one that
king triton gives ariel in the little
mermaid alberto's collection of objects
from the surface
is very much like the disney mermaid as
well our favorite connection between the
two movies though
is that jacob trombley the voice of luca
will actually be playing flounder
in the little mermaid remake wait it
feels like it's
still there yeah that's called phantom
tail you'll get used to it
in the town of puerto rosso there are
colorful walls
everywhere and one very special hidden
detail referencing another disney pixar
underwater character
in this scene we can see that the
etching in the concrete is none other
than hank the octopus from finding dory
you don't remember what we were talking
about
julia's fisherman father has a striking
look
and it's a bit of a different style to
the rest of the character designs we see
throughout the film
if he looks familiar to disney fans it's
because he looks almost
identical to the father in the disney
short la luna
this is definitely no coincidence since
lucas director enrico casarosa
also happens to be the writer and
director of la luna
this is how i came into the world
honestly we were a bit startled seeing
this chicken with a coconut shell on its
head being sold by a food vendor in a
market in raya and the last dragon
that bird is unmistakable there is no
doubt it's heihei
moana's chicken sidekick
hey hey it wouldn't be a disney movie
without a hidden reference to one of the
many items that frequently reappears
throughout disney pixar movies
in the hall of everything in seoul we're
treated to loads of hidden details
including the classic pizza planet truck
its first appearance actually goes all
the way back to toy story
welcome to pizza planet
in raya and the last dragon we know that
tong had a child who turned to stone
but fortunately we see tong reunited
with the child at the end
the little one is never actually given a
name but reportedly
tongler was what the child was referred
to as by the animators
what's extra special about this name is
that at the very end of the movie
credits in the production babies section
we see the name tongler listed among
them it's a name
cruising through the new york subway
system in seoul we see an advert for a
company called brang that appears
any guesses where this company has been
seen before taking a look back to the
movie inside out
it's the same name of the company that
riley's dad works for
he's even wearing their shirt here we
get it you're the best thanks hon
we're used to seeing the luxo ball
appearing bright as can be
in the background of some of our
favorite disney pixar movies
which is why we had a harder time
spotting it in seoul
however if we look closely tucked under
a table in 22's room
we can see the familiar ball looking far
more faded and shadowy than we've ever
seen it
not to mention luxo junior's quick cameo
shining down on a soul
wait are you actually helping me in the
movie onward we see a collection of
records
including one prominently featuring an
artist named dorothea williams
this was an early hidden detail hinting
at the movie soul
in which of course dorothea is the
famous jazz musician joe is so thrilled
to play with
call me joe dorothea i mean uh miss
williams said
it's a pleasure back in the seoul subway
joe and 22
end up hopping on train number 2319
this specific number has in fact
appeared in a disney pixar movie before
many many years ago when monsters inc
came out this same number was actually
used as the code at the child detective
agency
to alert when a human ended up in their
monster world george and i
are like brothers 23 19.
this number being included is extra
special because monsters inc was
actually the very first film that soul
director pete doctor
had directed for disney pixar
during the song shiny maui ends up
dancing on a pile of beautiful gold that
is very
very shiny one item in particular stands
out though
a very familiar magical lamp if we look
closely we can see that it's definitely
the genies lamp from aladdin
we've all been hearing joe ratzenberg's
voice for years
even if we didn't actually know it he's
voiced a character in every single
disney pixar movie since
toy story soul was the first exception
but his streak managed to be kept intact
in the subway when joe and 22 are
running through
we pass a man who is a bit of a younger
ratzenberg's likeness
keeping his epic legacy and streak alive
very good woody that's using the old
noodle it's a small and often missed
detail
but these chinese food boxes have
appeared throughout some of our favorite
disney movies
originally featured in a bug's life
we've also seen it in the incredibles 2
where they were sitting eating away
they weren't the only family to enjoy it
though riley's family had the same boxes
and inside out
we catch a glimpse of the classic box in
margaret's fridge and toy story 4
and then again in seoul on an office
worker's desk
the toy story 4 carnival is full of
color and exciting prizes
but the one that really caught our eye
was this beautifully designed guitar
the special instrument is unquestionably
the same one played in the film coco
bunny what are you doing the antique
shop in toy story 4 is filled with fun
and random objects
looking outside the shop we can see a
plate hanging in the window with an
intricate emblem on it
this special design just so happens to
be merida's family emblem from brave
once we actually get into the antique
shop we also sneak a peek at this
collection of
wall-e souvenir cups you can't be
serious
anyone remember this tune we can
definitely understand why the jingle for
triple dent gum starts to drive riley
crazy in inside out
the gun makes a few other appearances
though a pixie duster buys a pack of gum
and onward and in cars 3
triple dent happens to be a sponsor of
one of the cars
see as a little riley bounces on the
couch
our eyes are drawn to the magazine on
the coffee table our guess is that it's
a cooking or food magazine since there
is a familiar face on the cover
looks like colette tattoo the cook from
ratatouille has been doing
pretty well for herself i hate false
modesty
it's just another way to lie imagination
land has
so many little gems but we're taking a
look at one of the board games with a
little nod to an
older disney pixar flick finding nemo
this game called
find me displays an image of none other
than nemo
the fish who wound up being found during
the songs of moana we get treated to
such vibrant images and beautiful
illustrations
during maui's song you're welcome a
small fish swims across the screen and
if we take a good look
it's obvious that it's flounder from the
little mermaid
ah and then we were safe disney has been
known to include some darker
and not necessarily for kids hidden
details and this reference is one of
them
as moana is packing her boat a very
familiar looking carrot and branch are
packed away
these are two very key parts that make
up olaf
our favorite snowman we can't imagine
he'd do
too well in that heat best day of my
life
and quite possibly the last the genie
lamp wasn't the only
aladdin reference in moana here we see a
carpet that's been well loved and
definitely faded by the sun this isn't
just any carpet though
it's the flying carpet aladdin and
jasmine ride through the air on
when judy hopps's adventures in zootopia
bring us through tundratown
a tiny pair of elephants makes us do a
double take
taking a closer look we can see that
these two little elephants are actually
dressed up to look just like
anna and elsa i'm going to see
my sister we love finding all the little
references to past disney movies
and real life places and people
especially the ones that hint to future
productions
it's great to see the little tributes to
all those inside the disney family as
well
which hidden detail did you think was
best placed